Now, you've got a good idea of what jQuery has to offer.
You've learned that jQuery is just a JavaScript library and
it doesn't contain any hidden magic.
You've learned how to easily select anything in the DOM with jQuery.
You've learned a few basic DOM access methods and
you've manipulated the DOM with ease.
You've gone beyond that to add to and
remove from the DOM, and you've even learned how to use jQuery to
simply iterate through the DOM in a few lines of code.
But best of all, you've learned how to read through jQuery's documentation and
make sense of it all.
It's not some big, scary beast.
jQuery is a tameable library with methods that are as simple to
learn as they are to write.
You're ready to get out there and
start writing some elegant, concise front-end code with jQuery.
But before I let you go, there's one more jQuery trick I want you to learn.
In the very last part of the lesson, you'll find some written instructions about
one of the most interesting features of jQuery,
which is passing a function into the jQuery object to run on document.ready.
Are you feeling up for one last challenge?